it's a challenge inherent in placing an  extraordinarily complex machine within a  simple straightforward design and  creating software for that hardware  that's available everywhere while  staying true to the belief that a  product can be both aesthetically  pleasing and effortlessly almost  intuitively functional and that's what  we've achieved are we done  is that good is that good yeah what you  need when does this end  what more do you want than me let me go  please I'm begging you I've given you  what seven phones and capitalist are  them who are you is that you Daniel  where are you I don't know I don't know  head toward my voice Patrick Daniel a  little lost  wait um Oh buddy tiny  thank God how long have you been here I  have no idea but I think I saw a way out  of here over here  we're never getting out of I'm scared  and I'm so hungry what do they want I  found something Daniel Daniel okay  No  [Music]  someone's coming  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you